welcome to day two of the game SWAT
stage here at e3 2016 brought to you by
airheads bites it is my absolute
pleasure to kick off day two with The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild we've
got Daniel from the Nintendo treehouse
I'm obviously joined by GameSpot editor
Tamar Hussein Daniel what is it I mean
you're clearly repping the brand here
yes I have this wonderful scarf that I
have luckily so yes how exciting is it
but intended to be finally able to show
the world the new Legend of Zelda oh
it's been a while I know even the just
having a chance yes sure to finally
reveal the title breath the wild which
we showed that trailer yesterday which
shows off the art style this open air
exploration game that people get a
chance to experience and just seeing the
huge lines you've had outside the booth
people are waiting like four hours to
get in and get this whole experience and
even you go into it's a full
all-encompassing experience where
there's statues everything like that it
just it really brings the whole story of
legend result of a life in a new wave at
e3 Bernard done before so I'm really
excited I've seen the Statue it's very
impressive I only got a brief look
because it was after hours and one of
the security guards was like get out but
it was really nice a nice big picture of
it it's impressive like I love looking
at the K the color of the new Lincoln
his outfit and yeah it's just a super
impressive it's an awesome little statue
but you brought us a gift today haven't
you yes so yeah we sure a little bit of
game yesterday here on the stage of you
guys but now we're showing another part
because it's a very long demo it's
actually like a 35 minute long demo so
we're gonna show you the second part
which is a bit more focused on the story
elements of the game yes let's take a
look so we'll get up in a second but
yeah it's a chance to understand what
you kind of just thrown into this world
right up the beginning of the game don't
forget if you're watching on games for
TOCOM slash live slash III I'll be
taking a look at a chat taking a look
and offering your questions up to Daniel
if you have anything that you want to
know about Legend of Zelda LP
let us know all right here we go
wait cop link voice acting as well
so link here just basically wakes up
after a long slumber here we are you
kind of just start off here in this room
and basically this shining object is
kind of calling your attention a chance
to see what's going on and this is where
you first were introduced to the sheikah
slate which is an important tool in
links arsenals time around which is how
you're able to use a map you can
actually scan different enemies and it's
also how you're able to store this power
of runes which is something new to the
game where you actually when you go to
the shrines of trials you'll get a
chance to get runes embedded into the
sheikah slate that you can then use to
like throw bombs or freeze time on
certain objects as well and we'll get to
one of those shrines hopefully in this
demo as well and from what I understand
the shrines are different from actual
dungeons right correct correct that's
right there are over 100 if ur enshrines
of trials and there are so those are
speaking small in various ways and then
on the other hand there is the dungeons
which we haven't talked much about yet
so we'll have more talk about it but
there are dungeons so they are different
than the Strider obviously the name
shrine of trial kinds of trials implies
challenges are they kind of like similar
to what we'd see in a dungeon in terms
of a puzzle or is it like enemy base
what kind of what are these cherries
yeah a lot of more puzzle based
sometimes the shrines of trials have a
single solution to them sometimes they
have multiple solutions around bomb
times you go into a shrine you realize I
can't do this shrine yet right you might
have to mark it on the map and come back
to the later point
I'm question from the chat they're
asking does it's like gonna have
permanently three hearts as health bar
can and with only food buffs or can he
get one I said right now I'll be shown
say he starts with three hearts he will
have a chance to eat food that get those
busting at the yellow hearts we showed
yesterday and we'll have to wait till
later on to see how the how the rest of
the game expands from there look at that
yeah this is a beautiful introduction to
the game and you don't know what's going
on here they really kind of sets up
goal with the new medal of Zelda game is
is to present this open-world you know
we're used to starting off in small
villages and then you know exploring out
venturing out and discovering parts of
the world piece by piece whereas this is
kind of like here's everything it's
right you do it and that's why the whole
world is almost like a living character
of itself and you're always having to
move around and discover what you can
and that's kind of what's called the
breath the wild you don't know what
you're gonna discover as you're going
through the entire area one of the
questions I had was what it looks
honestly you've chosen a visual style
that were kind of used to seeing for the
last fuse all the games but there was a
period when you know so there was
everyone wanted a realistic Zelda or as
you've gotten stuck to like the almost
the Wind Waker style colorful or is this
is this kind of like the art style that
the series is settling into is this kind
of like how we we foresee this is this
is all the games are going to look for
the future mr. newm was always talked
about how every they approach each other
game is a different it's something new
they're gonna try to go after so they
approach it as they want to and it's not
always a permanent style I think this is
actually based a lot on a Japanese
animation style memory it's like a couch
a couch couch art style more designer on
the idea of looking at an open
environment of space and then trying to
capture that moment in a painting and
that's kind of what this tells a little
bit different that yeah is reminiscent
to a little bit like a wooden wicker
style but it is its owns to every Zelda
game with its own little art style on
the Wii U on the Wii on the 3ds on the
NES they've all had their own different
styles like so that's kind of just
people get to experience each time so
one of our SP a brown played this the
other day and impressions and it was
discussing this guy here he's kind of
like an NPC that you can choose to trust
or you can even avoid is that does that
speak to kind of like the broader way
that you integrate NPCs is there an
element of like kind of choosing how to
treat these characters and what they
offer you and that kind of stuff yeah no
that's very true very accurate I mean
that's the whole point even with the
shrines of trials with the characters
you'll discover all of it is that you
choose how you want to go about these
and explore and again you're right trust
this person not trust this person is he
helping you easy is you don't know like
you've just woken up in this long
slumber and you're in this world and
being called to help by this mysterious
voice so yeah it is up to you to decide
how you want to go through that first
combat encounter
and Esther you have to only looking for
things to pick up mom like right here
link is picked up an axe I was able to
use and yeah and that's cool thing what
the weapons you'll discover from the
enemies you fight you'll knock out their
weapons or defeat them and take their
weapons find treasure chest or sometimes
opens will be lying around it doesn't
have a different attack motion like you
saw there by holding down the attack
button links are charging it up and
spinning around versus using a sword you
discharge up and just do a quick spin so
there's all these different weapons
they'll have different styles to play
with what was your thinking behind
introducing these weapons that kind of
you can pick up on the flag because the
series legend of the series
traditionally I mean the weapons are
almost as iconic and beloved as the
characters themselves you know like the
master saw the shields you know the
hookshot the slingshot that kind of
stuff so having these kind of almost
just random elements like normal average
axes playing in it is that kind of
lesson the kind of impact that weapons
will have and the memorability of these
weapons those so we've shown so far yeah
the idea they want you to try
experiencing all these different weapons
that's why they have durability they do
break over time you can throw them at
people as well so you have to kind of
debate which weapons you want to use
they have different strengths but you
also as I mentioned once we get to it
you have also those rooms which you
that's they have a remote bomb there's
one that controls magnetic properties of
anything so people came to pick up an
object or giant metal boulder and
actually swing it around as a weapon so
there are those kind of aspects of it
that but you're bringing up from the
game before but again it's that whole
idea of every Zelda game in its own
tries to build a different experience to
enjoy and we're seeing link through
something which we haven't seen him do a
lot in the past which is just jump
randomly correct jumping you actually
can control when he jumps and that was a
really important mechanic that was
changing the game because on Numa wanted
people filled up the old to climb climb
is a big important factor as links been
running around you'll notice he has that
little green circle appearing which is
his stamina meter which is how Hobbit
Kalani can run for when he's climbing
and right here right now link is
actually sneaking up on this McCobb line
right here up what take them out so you
can see in the bottom right corner right
there there is that your purple meter
there that's kind of fluctuating that's
the noise meter so when you're trying to
sneak quietly behind an enemy you have
to be careful about that and slowly try
to sneak up on them if you want to get
out what's a sneak start of a strike
from behind them which I'll probably
yes actually almost basically killed
these characters a particular
essentially instantly so here in our
link has got another weapon now the
traveler sword so you're always kind of
looking for different weapons and items
to use you can only carry up to eight
you have to actually even debate which
ones you want to carry and hold on to
the weapons can break now yes right yes
and also enemies need to drop them in
fight yeah so it's more it's more
dynamics more scrambling around it's all
about that you want to be constantly
foraging even not just weapons but also
an another important element of the game
is cooking like usually when you run
around uhit's grass and whatnot hearts
would appear or rubies or anything this
around that doesn't happen you have to
actually go find things like apples or
or hunting a boar or a squirrel that get
items you can get together and then you
can eat them raw to get health back but
if you cook them you can even make them
even more powerful like more recovery or
buffs as you were mentioning before kind
of like having yellow hearts are some
kind of bonus or the ability to hold
resistance or run for a long period of
time right here after seeing a really
cool cutscene as well with the sheikah
slate they were able to unlock this
resurrection tower which is the first
time you really understand how huge this
world is conceptually
and there are multiple towers as you
just saw from that cutscene so you have
to determine how best to get to those
but right now you're on this plateau
which you can't if you go to the edge of
them you actually can't if you jump off
you'll die because you don't have any
way to get off of this right now
but you now brought this resurrection
tower to get a different kind of
perspective of this whole world to see
what's going on and see what's happening
so how big is the world and how how
densely populated is it I know that you
guys went on there are towns villages
MPD's you're not really showing them off
correct right now right now you're just
starting off on this plateau which when
in a moment you saw a little bit earlier
lake brought his map to look at what on
the sheikah slate and that map represent
this the plateau area on represents less
than 2% of the entire map and I said
I've seen people playing this demo alone
just exploring for 15 minutes you is not
enough time to go around this whole
thing this is just now you can see right
here discovering this is right now less
than 2% of the map so I'll have a little
have link to in a second is actually
puff up the map again and zoom it out
and you'll even get a better perspective
of how big this world really is and
that's really important that chicest
likes a really important tool that you
can use to mark points as I said
sometimes you go to a shrine a trial or
some location you want to come back to
you need to be able to mark those on the
map the thing about that is they're
gonna be fast travel between the points
yes you actually can at you and once you
when you unlock the shrines of trials
which is why it's important to go to
them is you can oh you give the trial
trials you can then mark that point fast
travel to it again the right here now
the other rush of rushing Tower brought
back up you're going to get more of the
story from the voice right now that
there's this is a castle and there's
something called calamity Ganon all
right it's locating this
and now you've discovered you been
asleep for over a hundred years and now
basically you need to help keep this
power contained so it's like this just
little introduction those piece of the
story to help keep moving you along and
deciding how you want to go through this
whole world to discover what you can
find try to help so how are we gonna
follow through the story is it just like
dedicated missions and quests and stuff
you can follow or can you take a really
open-ended approach to it and just do
things in different order if you do
things a different order it's up to you
to decide how you want to go through
everything and explore so there's no
it's not it's that's that's the big
change up that mr. onuma is talked about
is that it is not a previous selling and
a lot of time it's like this one this
one this one this is a lot more
reminiscent to the original Zelda the
NES like if you play the very first game
on the NES when you start playing you
can literally just go to the left or
right and you won't get a sword yeah and
you'll start dying so you have to be
worrying about all that please don't get
stuck in the story then I mean it's a
massive world we've seen people get lost
maybe go off the beaten path a bit how
do you ensure that they can get back on
it that's like me right now we're just
showing this component here which is
this is contained area of the plateau to
kind of work around discover right now
and you're kind of encouraged to nuts
like right here's an example you just
saw the old man come down here on a
paraglider which is essentially a tool
that link would need to get off of the
plateau and here's the claiming to gain
and call out so it's conversation right
here as we're going through this he's
giving the old man's game a little bit
more understanding of what this is and
that's how there's something inside of
this castle that you need to basically
help protect and essentially he's going
to now offer Lake the opportunity to
make a trade to cuz because he basically
needs a paraglider to get off so what
he's gonna do is basically see our
nationally isolated plateau and now you
can clearly you cannot get off of this
plateau so basically what you could
offer you to do is if you complete some
of the shrines of trial trials whole
baby make a trade with you okay so
that's kind of a way to encourage you as
he's trying to say they kind of
encourage those pieces along be right
there'll be those moments to kind of
encourage where you want to go at the
same time you can also just go off the
beaten path and do whatever you want to
but we'll get more to that later on as
we start discovering more of the world
and showing more of the game off to
really show how that's gonna help people
move along
in terms of what these story is
exploring obviously we will you know the
focus will be on links quest to you know
defeat and contain the power and defeat
calamity again and but it also seems to
be one of the most mysterious links in a
really long time we're used to having
seen you know him grow as a child in a
village but this is like a link that's
just emerge from a slumber after a
hundred years how much of that kind of
backstory and why he's in that slumber
and what happened before is explored
that has overall I'm the same point you
I'm also waiting to discover that more
and see what mr. onuma has to say about
the game in the future and that is true
I mean again that's why I keep a lot of
it comes back to think about that that
original Zelda game so the same way
within the first adult the game you just
were kind of thrown into it unless you
read the manuals a little bit of story
in the manual from back in the day so
yeah so it is more about that sense of
discovery you're not in a village like
in previous ones but as you said before
mr. Newman said there will be towns
there will be more stuff going on
but we'll get to that a later point in
the future so this is the one of the
first so the shrine is yellow right now
which is signifying that you have not
gone into a certain shrine so actually
if you were able to get to a higher
point you could scan around the area
there are other shrines to find just the
the shrine of OMA now and you can use
the sheikah slate now to activate it and
now once it's turn blue now you can fast
travel this location in the future
it's the first sequence to go inside the
shrine of trial and this read a chance
to actually earn your first rune and
runes uh presumably what you trade with
the old man
yeah second as he was asking you for to
see what you can complete his Chinese
that's what he's offering to trade is
that old man kind of showing up
regularly with new items or is it that's
really that's the first time you seems
when you come when you come out you see
him by the fire and then he kind of
meets you when you meet me you bring up
when you come down from the Resurrection
tower but you dint you don't know do you
trust him who is he
that's this part of the mister you saw
have left to discover what whose voice
is that that you hear when the game is
playing like who's talking to you who's
guiding you along and you don't know yet
because we have a history of mysterious
helpful people appearing and then at the
very last moments revealing themselves
to be an important key figure my
suspicions already kind of peaked with
this guy yes no I'm curious yeah it's
always funny when they have the name
just old man like you're like what yes
yeah there's so many and I'm sure people
can be making their own assumptions of
who it's gonna be and that's part of
though I love seeing that conversation
and people have been trying to turn
what's going on and here's yes by going
into the shrine of trial here you get
now the the the chicest ladies know
being in banded with that power of this
rune and this actually a pretty cool
rune room you have here which is uh
Magnus's which is the ability to control
objects that have metallic properties
and they'll have that first puzzle
mechanic to go into this question from
the chat they're asking how will they
handle the dungeons being able to be
played in any order in the past you
needed items from other dungeons to
complete them it seems like you'd only
need the I need the item to get in that
dungeon that the puzzles would be a bit
easier well that's what in the shrines
we're showing now that these are the
shrines we haven't seen dungeons yet so
that's let's look at a future point
and see what those are like but the
shrines right right now the shrines were
showing here in this demo yes you do get
the power of the rune approached the
beginning and have to then decide how to
use that to get through it
to discover what is at the end of the
shrine which we'll get to hopefully as
we're going through this right now and
that's something people discover some
will become more complicated so it'll be
harder and that's the whole point that
you might get to certain try certain
shrines that you
get through yet and you'll have to
figure out how best to come back market
come back to it later
do I need certain runes already embedded
in me embedded in the sheikah slate how
is that gonna play out not something to
kind of figure out so I read online that
it's possible to start the game and
immediately go to the final boss is that
true well you couldn't right now you're
picking up the plateau yet so you
couldn't go there and that's something
and you're right it's similar that you
might try to head toward the final area
but you might be enemies you even
discover or the would you start on your
way there might be too hard for you to
get through so you might have to get
other women and discover other areas and
explore those areas before you can come
back right areas you couldn't get
because obviously you know the legend of
zelda serie especially ocarina of time
has become quite a staple in the
speedrunning community reason yes and
I'm sure people going to try to figure
out yeah I'm sure there's gonna be a
community trying to figure out the
minimal the amount of items that you
need to get to the final mission I think
which shrines do you really have to
exactly like I'm sure there's over 100
so I'm sure gonna have a field day
trying to grow which ones you really
have to go through like shrine to shrine
15 shrine whatever to gather go through
all of that
alright I'm afraid we are nearing the
end of our time perfect we're always at
the end of the shrine right now here as
well quickly will see how quickly link
and get to the end is to show basic open
this door and this is where you discover
this mysterious monk and at the least in
this demo right now that we're showing
here and at the end of each of these you
do meet one of these monks who
essentially is working with the goddess
hylia okay and that's and that's part of
the mission you don't you really don't
understand what is that is so this is
that you prove that you actually
completed one of these and you do
receive a reward for that as well and
then the main that goddess forever smile
upon you do you guys talking about a
release date at all right now we've only
said that it's coming out in 2017
I know of your own keep my calendar pre
2017 but it will be releasing on the Wii
U and the NX simultaneously wonderful
Daniel thank you so much for joining us
thank you so much about showing us brand
new Zelda for more coverage from this
year's e3 make sure you don't go
anywhere
stay tuned to games.com